because the left is indefensible they've
got no good arguments to get people to
vote for them
in 2020 so now they've
they've truly devolved decayed
become debased the usual insufferable
celebrity psa has now become even
yuckier because you have all of these
some frequently washed up celebrities
left-wingers going out and saying you
gotta vote you gotta vote you gotta vote
but this time you wanna hear the hook
this time they're all naked
i'm completely butt ass naked i'm naked
i'm like naked there isn't a man behind
me these are my hands
why you want me to be naked i know what
you're thinking you're thinking ruffalo
um
put your clothes on to be honest i wish
i could
cover my hands with my boobs but here we
are i'm here to talk to you about voting
did you know
that ballads could be naked and if you
don't do exactly what i tell you your
ballot could get
thrown out this is uh my ballot just got
it
first of all when your ballot comes
you're supposed to read the instructions
read and follow the instructions that
come
with your ballot and if they say to use
the black pen use a black peg
i know that's like literally the least
sexy thing a completely naked person
could say but
[Music]
but i have cram like can of pepsi his
problem
[Music]
our founding fathers roll over in their
graves because
the left is kind of hilariously
depicting what they warned us all
against
you know the the founding fathers had
deliberative
discussion they had substantive debate
the federalist papers were
op-eds that were written to debate the
constitution
but they all said they said you know if
if license
takes over licentiousness if people just
give over to their base passions
we're not going to be able to have
self-government you need to be in
control of your passions
to have self-government and so what do
these people do they say we're all naked
we're all naked come vote for us
uh the psa was completely unconvincing
and really off-putting and really
really gross not even gross because
those people generally don't look very
good
but gross because you think gosh this is
how debased our politics
has become i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you